hey guys it is the 17th up September
today my name is Jess and this is games
what news the sign of life has been hit
with a delay pushing it's expected
release date into next year fans of the
JRPG series will have to wait a little
longer for the next installment as it's
now set to launch on ps3 and ps4 in the
summer of next year it was expected this
year persona 5 director katsura hoshino
previously said that this time around
the studio is attempting to go with a
challenge that fuses together a juvenile
school setting that is larger than life
together with a picturesque romance
adding this time it's about a group of
high school students that are being
chased by unexpected occurrences due to
the Justice they believe in reports
indicate the konami 'he's worldwide
technology director in charge of
overseeing the creation of the Fox
engine has left the company according to
game blog and IGN Julia meserole has
left the company for reasons which are
currently unknown well Nelson was in his
role Konami developed the Fox engine in
house which has recently been used to
develop metal gear solid 5 and pro
evolution soccer 2016 in May of this
year Konami president Hideki hayakawa
said that the company has a plan to
pursue mobile games aggressively adding
our main platforms will be mobiles
gaming has spread to a number of
platforms but at the end of the day the
platform that is always closest to us is
mobile mobile is where the future of
gaming lies Konami later clarified they
would still be creating content for
other platforms finally EA have said
that if you're keen to play the Star
Wars Battlefront beta you will
absolutely be able to battlefront
community manager Matthew Everett wrote
on EA Star Wars blog that the beta would
remain open once it's deployed although
a release date is yet to be announced he
added that the beta will include both
offline and online modes as well as
co-op and split screen co-op the beta
will also serve as a demo for an offline
co-op mission called survival where
players are dropped onto tat-away
and must face off against waves of
imperial AI foes the beta is due to land
on ps4 xbox one and via origin for PC
users let me know down in that comment
section if you'll be playing the Star
Wars Battlefront beta you can as a game
spot we've got stories on the release
dates for dark souls 3 and the witness
that is everything I have for you today
but do drop by same time tomorrow where
I'll have the top five stories of the
whole gaming week I will see then